some help is on the way for parents
struggling to find baby formula in the
coming days the federal government will
transport up to one and a half million
eight ounce bottles from switzerland to
the u.s but as meg oliver shows us it's
not only parents of babies who rely on
these supplies
for eight-year-old izzy bradford formula
is a lifeline how often do you have this
um
three times a day three times a day if
you don't have this what would happen i
get sick bradford suffers from a rare
metabolic disorder known as pku it
causes amino acid to build up in the
body we were told at six days of age
that she had this disorder and would
need to be on treatment for life her mom
sarah chamberlain says izzy relies on
special metabolic formula for about 70
percent of her nutrition what would
happen izzy's body if she didn't have
this metabolic formula she would start
to sort of break down psychologically
emotionally and physically could it
damage her brain
it would in a in long term not having
the formula would result in permanent
brain damage the formulas can
be life or death for these patients dr
paul levy is a metabolic geneticist his
concern is that even though abbott
laboratories who makes the formula is
ramping up all production again after
closing its plant following a recall of
other formulas delays could prove
dangerous even if they get sick and we
admit them to the hospital
the tools that we would use are based on
the formulas and their protein
restriction the formula izzy needs is
only available through prescription and
her mom is terrified of running out
how many cans arrived in your last order
we got two cans and how many we're
supposed to arrive 16. we're always sort
of walking a tightrope we need you know
enough protein to grow but not too much
protein and the formula is our safety
net in that
we're still balancing it's scary it's
frightening but we have the safety net
and right now we don't have the safety
net a safety net she needs as soon as
possible for cbs mornings i'm meg oliver